foreign
[Music]
thank you for coming for tonight's
performance of Louis CK
we have a few rules regulations before
we start due to covid-19 please don't do
anything during the show
also anal sex is not allowed in the
arena
please go to the lobby for the anal sex
today's Tuesday January 31st and boy do
we have a packed episode of the joke
World comedy news update this week
covering everything that's happened from
Louis CK's return to Madison Square
Garden Andrew Schultz acting alongside
Eddie Murphy in a brand new movie some
rare Bill Burr podcast appearances and
much much more all coming up next so
make sure you stay tuned get comfortable
and watch this video all the way until
the end and if you're just listening
give it a download I'll be out in a few
minutes right I'll be out in just a few
minutes so starting off with Andrew
Schultz and you people the movie came
out on Netflix on January 20th and has a
cast packed full of people from Comedy
including Andrew Schultz Eddie Murphy
Jonah Hill Sam J from SNL and Elaine
from Seinfeld the craziest cast I've
seen in comedy in years like the cast is
crazy little duvals in the background of
this scene I mean
it's unbelievable the movie is all about
Jonah Hill's character being white and
marrying into a black family Eddie
Murphy's character is the disapproving
father of Jonah Hill's potential wife
and Andrew Schultz plays a role of one
of Jonah Hill's old best friends Jonah
Hill's old friends all white clashed
with the bride's family all black and
Chaos in comedy ensue vaccine
is she gay Andrew Schultz doesn't really
have a ton of parts in this movie but he
is pretty funny when he's on camera as
many people have already said he's
basically just playing the part that he
does on flagrant in this movie
ice storm the capital
wow guys wow that was great yeah what
did you think of his decisions there
you're a good actor so I'm curious
what'd you think of what he did I
thought I thought he pulled it off I
thought for those situations
objectively great
it was all like he just had to make [__]
up it was just very cool that Kenny let
you ad-lib and a very smart choice to
just play yourself I thought that was
great yeah another cool thing about
Andrew Schultz acting in this movie is
he said for a very long time now that
Eddie Murphy is one of his biggest
Inspirations in comedy one of the
reasons that he does it in the first
place Andrew posted this picture on
Instagram the same day the film came out
and said quote I didn't ask for a pic
with Eddie but I did get to tell him
he's the reason I'm a comic that was
pretty damn cool the Louis CK back at
the Garden live stream Pay-Per-View
event took place on Saturday and boy did
it live up to all the pre-show hype
start to finish the event was about two
hours long and included opener Sean fish
and Adrian appalushi plus a special
guest jazz musician Ravi Coltrane who at
first I was like really dude we gotta
listen all this stupid jazz music oh my
god when is this gonna be over but by
the end of his set I was like damn this
guy's up and going off let's go jazz
[Music]
Louis himself doesn't come on stage
until about the 50 minute Mark of the
show but it is well worth the wait it's
hard to talk about the set in specifics
without giving away any jokes but I will
say it felt like watching a vintage
Louis CK hour just the way that he takes
the most simple premises like abortion
or religion or homeless people things
that have been joked about a million
times by literally every comedian in the
world he's still able to craft a stance
that's so unique and Preposterous yet so
funny it's truly amazing to watch a
master at work
hey everybody it's Louie and I'm going
to be this Saturday at Madison Square
Garden and I'm live streaming the show
on my website Louis ck.com you can live
stream it on Saturday or watch it for
the next 10 days after that and uh and
it's going to be a good show and I'm
with 3 000 people who just saw it so
they're going to tell you how much they
love the material what would you guys
think
[Applause]
thank you
if you missed out on the live stream
replay tickets will still be available
on Louis CK's website until February
17th for 25 which yeah that sounds
expensive for an internet show 25 bucks
but if you think about how much a ticket
to go see him at actual Madison Square
Garden would be in person 25 doesn't
seem that bad plus just like a real
fight you could split it up with some
friends and invite some people over to
watch Louie split up the cost that way
makes it a lot cheaper guest spots from
last week your mom's house had on Andrew
Santino two bears one cave was Bert and
Tony Hawk kill Tony had on Adam Ray and
Joe DeRosa flagrant talked with Sam J
Bobby Kelly was on take her shoes off
with Rick Glassman whiskey Ginger had on
the ru garbage boys and Bill Burr was
the guest on the Harland highway I want
you to Bill Burr to demonstrate tendons
if you can I don't think I can I'm gonna
pretend I'm a kid oh is this the curious
and you're gonna read oh [__] yeah well
already you're swearing huh I'll be I'll
be the kid reading the book and I'm
teaching about the real world you little
[__] I'll be the kid and I'll ask Daddy
to read
Daddy can you read me Curious George
absolutely my goateeed little son thank
you Daddy
all right ah oh this oh Curious George
Goes to the zoo this is one of my
favorites when I was yay okay this is
George George is a good looking little
Mom oh George is a good little monkey
and always very curious Today George was
feeling very excited The Man with the
Yellow Hat he owed taxes so he never
gave his name why did you throw that
part in daddy how did you know I threw
that part in you can't [__] read you
[__] daddy with the Yellow Hat don't sit
don't tell Mama said that it was taking
him to the zoo okay isn't that proper
for a full-grown man to take a hairy
little monkey boy to the zoo daddy he's
speaking in code they're gonna go score
some smack in this little red roofed
house here Daddy this is the first Red
Roof Inn hey filled with crack horse and
as they drove the man explained to
George that this wasn't just any Sioux
they're going to Brooklyn that they were
going to visit remember old dirty
Brooklyn shame on you uh it was called
Old Dirty Bastard it was a one of the ah
be nice daddy
go up to your mother right now and say
Wu-Tang Wu-Tang
read nice all right oh your mom's
already read this book so you know how
it goes all right it's called The Wild
Animal Park the man said all of the
animals roam around freely ah they must
be down Wall Street daddy uh when they
arrived George saw a huge Banner George
looked up at it but he could not read
the words because he's [__]
illiterate Daddy no swearing Daddy I
didn't I said fudgical a friendly
zookeeper explained let me tell you
something there's no such thing as a
friendly zookeeper what do you mean
Daddy they all hate animals and they the
only thing they hate more than animals
are children if you ever go to the zoo
and you get lost do not trust the zoo
Daddy stop all right stand near the
[__] reindeer and I'll find you Daddy
be tender you know I went to the zoo one
time in Iceland yes they actually had
pigeons in there because those were
exotic to them wow daddy and cockroaches
they actually brought insects there that
sounds fun what a nice add-on daddy it
was
did you take a creative writing class
son that you already know what an add-on
is are you making fun of me dad
absolutely Daddy I'll tell you right now
between you and me I don't think you're
mine daddy father and I went through a
rough patch six years ago yeah
that's our birthday we're gonna have a
party for her later on a party yeah of
course because it's a female Rhino right
that was a male Rhino they would have
skipped right over it Daddy you're too
angry a [__] broad Rhino could still
figure out how to have a goddamn
birthday at the zoo daddy Jesus Christ
let's go dig up some plant for the
[__] Queen this past weekend with the
Yvonne had ondrewski Jordan Peterson was
on The Joe Rogan Experience Bobby Lee
was the guest on the blocks podcast with
Neil Brennan Louis CK was on the Chrissy
chaos podcast Stuffy's World head on
Devon Walker and Alex English and Trevor
Wallace was on tigerbelly as far as new
stand-up specials go ones are either
coming out sooner came out recently Nate
bargati hello world came out today on
Prime video January 31st we're probably
gonna make a video reacting to that
Nate's special so let me know what you
think of it leave a comment about hello
world and keep an eye out for that video
coming out later this week maybe turn
your post notifications on that could
help other than that Roseanne Barr is
making her return to comedy with a brand
new special titled Roseanne Barr cancel
this which will debut on Monday February
13th on Fox Nation that does it for this
week's joke World comedy news update as
always thank you so much for watching
this video and supporting the channel in
general tomorrow we're uploading the
funniest moments of January best of
January 2023 yet another reason for your
post notifications to be on don't want
to miss best of January other than that
I don't have much for you the NFL has
rigged the officiating and Sunday's
Bengals and Chiefs game was atrocious
and just a slap in the face of football
to the spirit of competition it's a joke
if the Chiefs had any ethics and any
backbone and any morals they tell the
NFL that the Bengals should take their
place in the Super Bowl because that
just was not fair and that those refs
should serve prison time they should go
to jail for a few days okay best of
January coming out tomorrow
foreign
[Music]